DANIEL SIEBERG: Hi there.
I'm Daniel Sieberg with
Google Developers
Live here at I/O 2013.
And I'm joined right now by
Shalini Agarwal, who is a
product manager with Gmail.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yep.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Gmail, which
obviously for a lot of folks
has become indispensable
on the consumer side.
But what we're going to talk
about is not just the changes
people are going to see in their
inbox, but how the team
has thought what can other
companies do to really make it
more manageable and easier for
people to get through all of
that information that
they get every day.
So tell me about some of the
announcements that were made
here first of all at I/O.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
Great.
So yesterday we announced that
we were launching four
different types of actions
in the inbox.
And really, the motivation
behind it was that users have
a lot of email to process.
And each email takes a lot
of steps, a lot of
time to really manage.
So anything you want to do
involves a lot of steps.
We really wanted to bring those
steps and those actions
directly to the top level of the
inbox, so users can manage
their iterations with their
services much more quickly,
much more easily, and get
through the things that they
need to do.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So the idea of
these Quick Action Buttons or
however we want to describe
them, you don't
have to open the email.
They're right there.
We've had the chance to
test it internally.
And I feel like I've only
scratched the surface with
what you can do with them.
But it's right there as a button
within the [INAUDIBLE].
SHALINI AGARWAL: It's
right there.
The button is right there
at the top of the inbox.
For certain cases when you need
more information, you can
click on it and it opens up a
nice overlay with the key
information that you need
and the key actions.
And that's it.
It's really quite simple and
quite fast for users.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
Well, let's see it in action.
SHALINI AGARWAL: All right.
DANIEL SIEBERG: You've got
a demo here for us.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: You're going to
go into your virtual inbox,
we should say.
This is kind of your email.
SHALINI AGARWAL: It is.
The first action that we'll
take a look at is RSVPing.
So when your friends invite
you to events, or birthday
parties, or whatnot, you usually
get an email telling
you about the invitation.
And now with the action in the
inbox, you get a button on the
right-hand side, this RSVP
button right here.
And when you click on it, you
get the key information.
Here I can find out that
OK, it's a Taco Night.
The event was hosted
by Google Calendar.
And it's on Sunday at 7:00 PM.
And there's one other
person going.
If Clarence had entered
a location, that would
also show up here.
So with one click, I
open this overlay.
And another click, I hit yes.
Now he knows I'm going.
So that's it.
Gmail on the backend has sent
information to Calendar.
So if you want, we can
take a quick look
over at Google Calendar.
And here it is--
Taco Night.
And there it is.
Yes, I'm going.
This is Google Calendar,
but this could work
for any event service.
For example, Paperless Post is
one of our launch partners.
So when we launch this
feature, we'll be
launching it with them.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And so they
would choose to have this
added to their email campaign,
or whatever--
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: --they were
going to do with it.
It's something they build into
the email itself when they
send it out, essentially?
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
So it's actually very simple.
Our goal was to make it
extremely easy for developers
to do this.
So all they have to do is add
markup to their emails.
We've been working with
schema.org to try and get this
markup standardized and reviewed
by other parties out
there, other email clients.
And it's that simple.
They add some schema, that word
"markup," tell us about
the event, tell us about the
action, tell us where to send
the response once the user
takes it, and that's it.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And I hope too
obviously is that there would
be increased engagement with
people because it's so
convenient for them
to actually--
SHALINI AGARWAL: Exactly.
DANIEL SIEBERG: --just one
click and they're in.
Great.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Exactly.
When you host a party,
you want to know
if people are coming.
You want people to quickly
figure out if they can come
and respond.
And not just that, when I get
invitations to parties, I
first want to see the
information about the party.
Then later on, I might decide
if I'm going or not.
And then on the day of the
party, I'll go back and find
the email to get the key details
of like what time is,
where it is.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right.
SHALINI AGARWAL: So we wanted
to make all of those steps
really, really easy.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's great.
Now you've got a few
more things you can
show us here, right?
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
So the second type of action
is what we call
the One-Click Action.
And really, it's just
one button to
take a specific action.
So in this case, Google Offers
has already started marking up
their emails with this schema.
So when I get the daily
email from them--
today's happens to be from
Michael's Stores,
which I shop at a lot.
I get picture frames
done there.
So with one click, I
can say, get offer.
And, looks like it
didn't work.
But normally what would happen
is when I click a button, I
would go over to Google offers,
and it would show up
right there.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
SHALINI AGARWAL: But clearly,
we had a little
demo breakdown here.
DANIEL SIEBERG: It could easily
be a connectivity
issue, which I think it is.
I see down on the
right there--
SHALINI AGARWAL: There it is.
Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: --that we've
lost the Wi-Fi, so.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Let's
try it one more time.
Reload here.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Here we go.
Here we go.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Now,
let's try again.
I click the button.
There it is.
DANIEL SIEBERG: This
looks promising.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Gmail.
DANIEL SIEBERG: There you go.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Sent the
message to Google
Offers, so I go here.
I reload this tab also.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yep.
SHALINI AGARWAL: And--
DANIEL SIEBERG: There it is.
SHALINI AGARWAL: There it is.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Very nice.
SHALINI AGARWAL: One click.
Didn't have to open email.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yep.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Didn't have
to leave the inbox.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yep.
SHALINI AGARWAL: And
I can keep going
on to the next item.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
fantastic.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And then, the
next one, now these-- so tell
me again, which ones were
announced here and which ones
are coming soon?
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
So we announced four.
We announced the RSVP that we
saw, the One-Click button--
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yep.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Rate and
Review, and a Go To action,
which is really for complex
actions that can't be achieved
from the inbox.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
SHALINI AGARWAL: So for those,
you actually need to go off to
a site, a deep link, and
complete your actions.
Those were the four that
were announced.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
And is the next one one of the
Rate and and Review ones you
can show us?
SHALINI AGARWAL: The next one
is the Rate and Review.
Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
SHALINI AGARWAL: So again, we're
working with Seamless as
one of our life partners.
And so when you order through
them, you order food from a
restaurant, they can send you an
email that asks you to rate
your experience.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yep.
SHALINI AGARWAL: And
that's important,
because you want to tell.
When you rate your experiences,
you get better
suggestions.
So your experience about
the service is
better down the road.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yep.
SHALINI AGARWAL: So with the
Review option, similar to
RSVP, you get the key
information you need--
the name of the restaurant,
whoever you ordered through, a
picture of whether
it's a product.
Here it's food.
It could be a product,
a movie, anything.
And you can quickly rate
and review, right
in this little box.
So you say hey, solid meal.
Will order again.
And that's it.
You can see that Gmail is
sending the rating to
Seamless, and that's it.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Does it get
posted anywhere, or shared
anywhere else?
SHALINI AGARWAL: At
seamless.com.
DANIEL SIEBERG: It goes
to seamless.com.
OK.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
That's great.
SHALINI AGARWAL: It goes
to seamless.com.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I think
from a convenience
standpoint, that's awesome.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Sometimes you
just are a little reluctant to
go into your email and then
go to the site, and
so on, and so on.
For Seamless or any other
company, this is obviously
going to be a big
win because--
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: --now they're
really going to get that kind
of people actually responding
to these things rather than
just deciding not to.
SHALINI AGARWAL: It's
kind of amazing.
I counted the number of steps
it takes to actually do this
without the button.
And it takes six steps.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I believe you.
I am not surprised.
SHALINI AGARWAL: And that's
if you remember your login
information and all
that stuff.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yep.
Yep.
It's a deterrent for
some people.
It just is.
OK.
Now the next one, can we talk
about the dial feature here?
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
This is another--
it's the same thing as the One
Click Action that we saw from
Google Offers.
But the really cool thing, I got
to say that the One-Click
action is my favorite, because
you can do so many different
kinds of things with it.
Any type of use case that
is just a one click
action can be done.
So in this case, it's an email
that's actually from
[? Esna, ?]
which is a communication service
that's letting me know
that I missed a call
from Claudio.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
SHALINI AGARWAL: And so they've
enabled this One-Click
Button, so when I dial it, so
when I click the button, Gmail
tells us now, OK, the
user clicked the
button that you added.
And what they do on the backend
is dial, is connect
the call between
me and Claudio.
So the moment I click it, both
our phones start ringing.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Got you.
OK.
SHALINI AGARWAL: I could click
it now, but then Claudio's
phone might be ringing, and
I don't know where he is.
He might be in a session
somewhere.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And then the
next one after that, this is
not available just
yet, the next.
SHALINI AGARWAL: The two
that are available as
of today are the--
or actually, sorry, as of
yesterday-- are this Go To
Action, which is the sort of the
short cut to a deep link
on another site, and the Button
Action, which is what
you see here with Dial
and Get Offer.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yep.
OK.
SHALINI AGARWAL: The ones that
are coming soon are RSVP and
Rate and Review.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
So the Check In one for flight,
that's actually
available today.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah,
it's available today.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's great.
That's great.
So show me what will
be involved here.
SHALINI AGARWAL: All I would do,
so this button is actually
not going to work.
But all would do is I click--
when you receive this email,
what do you want to do?
You want to check in
for your flight.
It's not that you need to
necessarily open the email.
It's not that you need to, but
if you do decide you want to
open the email, what we will
have is a beautiful flight
card at the very top, similar to
the cards you see in Google
Search and Google Now, at
the top of the email.
And it will give you the
key information--
your connection times, your
flight details, the airport
information, and also if the
flight's on time or not.
I can't tell you how many times
I've gone to the airport
to find out that my flight
was delayed.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Delayed or
cancelled all together.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Exactly.
So here, when you get the Check
In email, you'll also
get this beautiful card.
It's not launched yet, but
it'll be launched soon.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So there
is a tie-in then with
Now and with Search.
I mean, we should point out that
this is all part of what
we're talking about, right?
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
Yeah.
It definitely is.
For example, if here we have
a oceanic airlines.
But if any airline were to
mark-up their emails, their
confirmation emails, or check-in
emails, with schema.
That same information
will feed many
products, if you will.
So today, it'll enable
experiences in Gmail, and into
Google Now, and Google Search,
and potentially other
experiences across the way.
So that users can get the
information that they need,
that they are getting from
via email, at the
best time and place.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right.
This all seems to be tied into
the theme of getting the
information you need quickly,
sort of at a glance, and then
moving on to whatever else
you need to be doing.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Exactly.
Exactly.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Now tell me, it
feels like there's so much
potential for this.
Can you tell us what's on the
horizon here, where you see
this going?
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
I mean this is--
we're really excited
about this.
And it's really just
the beginning.
Over time, we'll be adding
more types of actions.
Over time, we'll be adding more
types of social data.
So I talked about the Flight
Card, but also we'll have
things for events and hotels.
And we'll be expanding those
experiences across Google.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's great.
What's the response been from
the merchants and the
companies that you've
talked to?
And maybe you can, I know you
mentioned a few of the
partners like Seamless, but if
you wanted to run down maybe a
few that have been really
actively involved in this.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah,
definitely.
So we've gotten a
lot of response.
Because at the end of the day,
companies and services care
about user engagement.
And so they're sending their
users emails because they want
to tell them something
or do something.
And so it's been pretty exciting
as we demo these
types of features for partners,
and the different
kinds of use cases they
come up with.
So every partner we have, we
start the conversation by
saying, tell us about the things
that you do with your
users and what communications
you have with them over email.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right
SHALINI AGARWAL: Because the
types of things, it can be
anything from, for
example, Spotify.
When you subscribe, so I use
Spotify and I listen to my
brother's playlist.
I subscribe to them.
So every time he adds music,
which is actually pretty often
which is fun, they
send me an email.
DANIEL SIEBERG: You get a
notification-- an email.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Exactly.
And so now, I can, now those
emails have a button on the
right-hand side that say,
listen to the song.
And when I click that button,
it opens a tab.
And if my player's installed,
it just starts playing.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
very clever.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's great.
And some, I can see some of
these businesses would
actually want to do multiple
versions of it.
I mean--
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: You could get
one like an airline might want
a review, as well as to remind
you of your flight.
SHALINI AGARWAL: How
was your flight?
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Exactly,
because I get
those emails too.
So it's a bit of both.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: You talked a
bit about the motivation
behind all of this, but maybe
you can kind of expand on that
a little bit, just in terms of
what people have to deal with
in their inbox.
I mean, we're all coping with
information overload sometimes.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I imagine the
team really thought hard.
In some ways, this feels
really intuitive to me.
It almost feels like this hasn't
been there before?
Like it feels like something
that just makes sense.
Can you reveal a little bit of
the thinking in all of this?
I think it's really neat.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah, so it
basically boils down to each
email today looks the same,
but really it contains all
sorts of different types
of information.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right.
SHALINI AGARWAL: And so, it
should be more tailored.
It should be easier to figure
out what is it you want.
It should be more structured.
Email is extremely unstructured
today.
So everything you do, you
have to figure out.
The user has to do the work, to
figure out what it is that
they're being asked to do, what
information is in there,
and dig for it, and open
different tabs, and it's like
a funnel type of process.
DANIEL SIEBERG: [INAUDIBLE].
Right.
SHALINI AGARWAL: And
it's frustrating.
And so often times, you probably
know this as a user.
I feel it.
We see it.
A lot of emails go unanswered
or unopened.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah.
SHALINI AGARWAL: But that
doesn't mean the user doesn't
want to do those things.
It's just too painful.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I think that's
an excellent point, because I
think there's best intentions
perhaps on both sides--
SHALINI AGARWAL: Exactly.
DANIEL SIEBERG: --but not enough
of a sort of an easy
bridge between the requests
and the action
to actually do it.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Exactly.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And now, if
you're just asking somebody to
click one button, it
doesn't get much
simpler than doing that.
SHALINI AGARWAL: No.
No.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Anything else
you want to mention in terms
of what's coming?
SHALINI AGARWAL: So I would just
say that we definitely
want to add more actions.
We're really excited about this
concept of In Place Actions.
So we are going to work closely
with our existing
partners and we want to
hear from developers.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I was going to
say, I imagine you're going to
discover a lot of ways that
it can be used that--
SHALINI AGARWAL: Exactly.
DANIEL SIEBERG: --hadn't
been thought of before.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Exactly.
And we already did, you know,
through the process, we've
already come up with a few
actions and we want to add
over the coming months, because
they will be good
platforms for lots of
different cases.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right.
SHALINI AGARWAL: And help users
connect with their services.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And this
is all measurable, I
mean, by the companies.
They could really see the kind
of engagement attraction that
they're getting from people
looking at this.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah, I mean,
they can track their links.
They can track when you
just click on links.
They can track when the servlets
on a backend are hit.
So when we send them a
response, they know.
And so they can easily
track that.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's great.
All right.
Well, Shalini, thank
you so much.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Thank
you, Daniel.
DANIEL SIEBERG: This
has been a great--
I've learned a lot.
I mean I use Gmail all the
time, but I think this is
going to be a fantastic
addition to it.
SHALINI AGARWAL: We hope so.
We're pretty excited.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's great.
Thank you so much.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Thanks.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
That's going to do it
for now here on
Google Developers Live.
Stay tuned for lots more
content, right here.